und jetzt muss man wirklich tacheles
reden wie sieht's bei ihnen zu hause aus
mit der hausarbeit ist die gerecht
verteilt also so richtig gerecht so
fifty fifty ja küche wäsche waschen
putzen und so weiter ist das halbe halbe
unsere neue grüne
bundesfamilienministerin anne spiegel
die will genau das halbe halbe sagt sie
dann ist es gerecht ist das eine sache
in die die politik eigentlich rein
regieren sollte in ihren haushalt wir
haben uns mal umgehört wie es bei ihnen
zu hause aussieht ob es gerecht zugeht
ob sie finden dass das sache der politik
ist
ministerin nicht gut warum
weil das bild sehr veraltet ist muss nur
die frau die ganze hausarbeit macht und
sich um die kinder kümmert und was
heutzutage ja durch die
gleichberechtigung generell alles schon
sehr verändert ist ja ich würde mir
schon wünschen dass aufgeteilt ist
hälfte hälfte finde ich gut ja dass man
im haushalt helfen finde ich sehr gut
warum warum beides bisschen bei männern
noch ein manko ist was soll noch machen
wir ja mal putzen es macht ja wenig
motion wiederum haushalt wie viel machen
sie denn ich koche wasche ich
sage sogar raus zum beispiel mutter
seien sie gehe zur schule lernt und und
dann ich sauber machen oder kuchen oder
etwas kinder der eine macht man mehr im
haushalt der andere kosten mehr aufs
kind aus und andere nächsten tag ist es
dann umgekehrt ist komplett ausgeglichen
also dass man das ich mir ja im haushalt
betätigen finde ich an sich nicht
schlecht
wir sind ja in einer gesellschaft in der
gleichberechtigung mittlerweile immer
wichtiger wird auch wenn die frau dann
irgendwie fällt man geld mehr geld
verdienen sollte als wenn man das dann
auch in kinderzeit gehe das ist auf
jeden fall gar kein problem dann sind
meine frau macht schon mehr im haushalt
würde ich sagen ich bin dafür vollzeit
arbeiten sieben drei viertel ich
versuche natürlich zu helfen ich denke
eine gesunden partnerschaft sollte man
miteinander reden und das nicht von
irgendjemanden das entscheiden lassen
ich denke nicht dass man dann den
politiker und politikerinnen braucht die
sagt wer was im haushalt zu machen hat
er und genauso wie hier bei uns hinten
kann das dann bei ihnen auch sehen nicht
schlecht oder keiner habe es geht auch
anders also es geht definitiv anders man
muss nicht ja sich komplett entkleiden
um hausarbeit zu machen muss man muss
sagen aber ich weiß nicht wie sich die
bundesfamilienministerin das genau
vorstellt eine sache stellt sich aber
ganz genau vor nämlich dass es
halbe-halbe eben ist zu hause mit der
hausarbeit männer sollen
selbstverständlich die hälfte der
familien und hausarbeit machen fifty
fifty also sagt die neue grüne
bundesfamilienministerin eine spiegel
und focus kolumnist jan fleischhauer der
lebt die jetzt schauen was die
familienministerin heute also fordert
erst als symbolbild für die
gleichberechtigung seine frau arbeitet
zwischen 50 und 60 stunden die woche und
da ist es selbstverständlich dass
kinderbetreuung und haushalt gerecht
geteilt werden erst uns jetzt aus dem
homeoffice zugeschaltet guten morgen
herr fleischhauer brauchen die
unterstützung der politik damit der mann
auch den haushalt macht
es ist ja so ein bisschen so seid nett
zueinander und flucht nicht so viel
nicht so viele böse worte benutzen ich
meine bei dem vorschlag von frau spiegel
fragt man sich was kommt denn jetzt also
außer dem appell kommt jetzt das
gerechte haus arbeitsgesetz ja das ist
meine innovation
jahr rechnen sie damit also das ist doch
tatsächlich der anfang hier wird doch
einen regiert jetzt also jetzt wird doch
gesagt jetzt gucken wir mal genau hin
wie ist das dabei den fleischers zu
hause ist das wirklich so gerecht wie
der immer sagt ist das 50 50 aufgeteilt
naja also jetzt kommt die anne spiegel
kamera installiert ja sozusagen mist
oder was also ich finde ich muss mir
nichts vorwerfen also ich stehe um als
erster auch in der familie viertel nach
sechs mal um viertel nach sieben muss
der sohn zur schule gebracht werden ich
wohne im pool hatten vor ort die schule
das leider am jakobsplatz also direkt
mitten in der stadt dann fahre ich
wieder zurück und dann erledigt sodass
eine andere
ich meine ich finde er grundsätzlich so
und so
dass wir möglicherweise deswegen immer
nach der politik rufen in solchen
situationen weil wir es halt zu hause
nicht richtig hinkriegen ja also das ist
ja auch so ich würde mal an jede frau
appellieren schon bei der partnersuche
augen auf ja
es ist ein typ der mit anpackt ja da
kriegt man relativ schnell eindruck oder
nicht und
also spätestens damit die kinder ins
haus stehen würde ich mal vorher mal ein
gespräch darüber führen wir machen es
anschließend
ihre frau hat also glück gehabt bei der
partnersuche aber wenn wir schon so
privat jetzt über ihr familienleben
sprechen ist es tatsächlich so dass wenn
ihre frau dann abends von der arbeit
nach hause kommt dass sie schon das
essen gemacht haben
ich würde sie gar nicht an ihren lassen
würde ich gar nicht kochen kann ja also
das
darf jetzt nicht also ich hoffentlich
sie guckt jetzt nicht zu er da trägt ist
auch der schelte ja also wird sie mir
sagen sie also wir natürlich ein
fabelhafter kochen.de als die
kinderstadt mindestens würden darauf
beharren dass ich den kochlöffel in die
hand nehme
sie arbeitet damit schaffen wir endlich
aber das ist die das ist ja das ist ja
immer so statistiken jetzt angeführten
und auch vom spiegel hatte irgendwelche
statistiken zur hand und nach denen
angeblich die männer also weniger im
haus machen als die frau ja dann würde
ich mal sagen
jetzt kommt es drauf an also wenn er
morgens um acht aus dem haus geht und um
18 uhr nach hause kommt also klar
klassische familienmodell ja und coole
mannschaft dann fertig so ein bisschen
viel verlangt wenn du gerne auch noch
den staubsauger in die hand nehmen muss
nur damit es irgendwie gerecht zugeht
also man kann ja nicht nur auf die aus
arbeit fokussieren sondern ich finde da
muss aber sozusagen das gesamte
arbeitsvolumen in so einer familie mal
angucken und da würde ich gern würde ich
sagen gehört erwerbsarbeit charlott dazu
ja aber das scheint ja genau der sinn
dahinter zu sein dass sie eben sagen
möchte eine hausarbeit ist eben auch
vollwertig das müssen wir eben mit
einrechnen und dann am ende irgendwie
unter alles halbe-halbe machen was
glauben sie denn wie das bei der
ministerin eigentlich läuft also da hat
man jetzt auch nicht so viel freie zeit
noch zu hause so viel zeit glauben sie
dass bei anderen spiegel zu hause das
bei den anderen ministern und
ministerinnen die hausarbeit so 50 50
geteilt ist dass minister und
ministerinnen da richtig gut bei
wegkommen das ganze geht ja glaube ich
auf ein interview zurück dass sie in der
welt geschrieben hat oder wirst du dazu
befragt man sagt ja sie hätten ein
bisschen zu weit die andere richtung
übertrieben
natürlich nicht alle frau spiegel die
war ja vorher schon ministerin jetzt
diese bundesministerin als die wird
jetzt nicht den ganzen tag auch zu hause
dann mit dem freelander hand stehen und
mit dem staubsauger in der anderen das
macht natürlich im wesentlichen der mann
durch sondern die dienstboten und ich
glaube in dem fall hat der mann auch
sogar seinen job aufgegeben bei annaberg
ist das ja auch nicht anders da es erst
zurückgetreten und ich glaube jetzt da
sogar ganz ganz die segel gestrichen
das geht doch gar nicht anders also wenn
einer wenn einer voll weg ist für sich
damit was ich ja meine da muss der
andere im haus mehr tun ich würde das
das lustige finde ich einmal diesen
diskussionen ist darauf kommt ja auch
frau spiegel zu sprechen all das sei ja
wahnsinnig also anstrengung für die
frauen und so sehen die sozusagen
gehetzt ja also zwischen kochtopf und
und hinter windel und und mülleimer hin
und her düsen wenn wir uns mal die
statistiken angucken also wer stirbt
früher ist aber die männer ja wer hat
früher herzinfarkt wo sind die
suizidraten höher der über die männer
also ich weiß nicht vielleicht sollten
wir uns mehr auf die hausarbeit
konzentrieren das ist knallhart wann
haben sie zuletzt geputzt herr
fleischhauer heute morgen ich habe drei
kleine kinder zu hause alles gibt was
glaubt ihr wie das aussehen würde wenn
ich hier nicht wirklich nicht entstehen
das brillant nehme immer die kleinste
ist jetzt neun monate alt und jetzt habe
ja noch mikron im haus also die kita
gestern geschlossen
weil in der gruppe mit meiner
zweitältesten tochter also dass das böse
wie iris zugeschlagen hat also
gute kann sich an ihnen wirklich ein
beispiel nehmen vielen dank für das
gespräch jan fleischhauer